so the Swisher who's been playing out
over the weekend and it seems to me that
far from settling down about it
everyone's getting more and more
agitated particularly with regard to
Owen Paterson who are readers will see
as a as a great loss yeah I can get this
was a classic that the weekend after the
reshuffle before um I what's interesting
about Owen Paterson is that if you read
his piece and sunday telegraph
complaining he wasn't saying I was SAT
for being a a right-wing you're a
skeptic he was saying that he was
attacked for taking on the green blob
yes and that was a deliberate echo of
Michael goes language about the
education establishment I think this is
one of those dangerous and damaging
stories for Cameron that is running
which is that anyone in the government
who took on vested interests ultimately
Cameron was not prepared to back them up
in so i'm passin got sacked michael gove
but promoted Nick Foles it was a
Planning Minister yes he got promoted
but his successor and Brandon Lewis is
not someone who wants to continue with
the same reformist CEO of it but bowls
had so I think I think you see haven't
you seen enough this isn't about right
or left this is actually about the
ministers who felt they were doing
something feeling that number 10 having
encouraged them to set off from a part
as then pulled the rug from ultra and I
suppose cannon would say this is all
about calming down I'm not busy fights
but only another question is whether you
can hold formal reform without fighting
can you just stand still yeah I think
never dangerous as Charles serving up
the magazine this week is with every
vested interest every can of lobby group
will now shout that bit louder against
you know inverter corners Tory cuts or
the Tory agenda because they will have a
sense that if they can make enough noise
caused enough trouble get enough front
pages then the government will think
again I'm in terms of the new secretary
state for education I mean the idea is
she said she stands by ghosts reforms
why would she then as a sort of first
move dismiss both his special advisers I
think there is an oven there's none here
I think it is fair enough that that
model go has had is actually he has an
property man special advisers but they
have been incredibly personally loyal to
him I
understand why someone coming in would
want a new team whose loyalties work
worked at them I mean that the big
chance for her is whether she sticks
with the gove agenda I think there is an
acceptance that we're not going to see
the same pace of reform yeah that was
before but the question is whether the
line is held essentially and I think
that I think that what we're gonna see
her do is she's she heart tactic from
those who've spoken to us seems to be to
concentrate on areas but Michael Gove
wasn't perceived to be as interested so
I think we're here a lot from her about
vocational education early years while
kind of almost parking the other reforms
on the other side on academies in
preschool right what do you think that's
about their shovels well I suppose the
ending things have no ver the weekend
was at the beginning of an attempted
alignment or pretended alignment of the
so-called right I mean this the the the
Patterson story the the claim that there
are now a few disgruntled quite powerful
fallen ministers of the right who could
genuinely cause trouble now for the
prime minister III don't know we'll see
countering against that of the results
of polls allegedly saying that they've
been a bit of an uplift and Tory
prospects and them right if Cameron
believes that then he won't believe
anything